these are 57 the nays
are 43. for a second time donald trump
acquitted of high crimes and
misdemeanors by the u.s senate donald
john trump former president united
states
is not guilty as charged the charge he
incited the crowd ahead of the violent
riot at the capitol on january the 6th
57 senators said he did including seven
republicans
but that's not enough for the two-thirds
majority to convict
this was about choosing country over
donald trump
and 43 republican members chose
trump they chose trump
it should be a weight on their
conscience today
the day started with a surprise the
democrats asking for witnesses
a move which could delay the process we
would like the opportunity to subpoena
congresswoman
herrera regarding her communications
with house
minority leader kevin mccarthy and to
subpoena
her contemporaneous notes that she made
regarding what president
trump told kevin mccarthy in the middle
of the insurrection if they want to have
witnesses
i'm going to need at least over a
hundred
depositions not just one both sides
though wanted to bring this to a quick
end
so reached agreement which meant no
witnesses and a move
to closing statements from the man who
led the prosecution
and appealed to senators to meet the
moment senators
this trial in the final analysis is not
about
donald trump the country and the world
know who donald trump is
this trial is about who we are
who we are this is almost certainly
how you will be remembered by history
that might not be fair
it really might not be fair but none of
us can escape the demands of history
and destiny right now trump's team so
often echoed
the ex-president's words this
impeachment has been a complete
charade from beginning to end the entire
spectable
spectacle has been nothing but the
unhinged pursuit of a long-standing
political vendetta against mr trump by
the opposition party it is time to bring
this const
unconstitutional political theater to an
end it is time to allow our nation to
move forward
what the result in donald trump made his
first comment since the trial began a
statement from his florida home
thanking senators for their vote but
insisting this
is yet another phase in the greatest
witch-hunt in the history of our country
no president has gone through anything
like it one of his closest allies in the
senate
who voted to acquit him made it clear
the former president
was responsible for what happened
president trump is still liable for
everything he did while he was in office
as an ordinary citizen unless the
statute of limitations is run
still liable for everything he did while
he's in office
didn't get away with anything yet
yeah the decision here means that donald
trump will not be excluded for running
from political office in the future
he could run again for the presidency in
2024
his supporters say he should and he
would win
but despite the not guilty plea january
the 6th will
always be attached to donald trump's
presidency and the day when democracy
was threatened in america
alan fisher al jazeera on capitol hill
well earlier allen caught up with one of
the trial impeachments managers stacy
plaskett and she told him trump's guilt
is clear despite the result
a majority of senators did believe us
and in hearing the speech
of senator mcconnell they know that we
proved the charges as well
you know shame on them for holding
themselves to
an excuse that they gave themselves on a
jurisdictional issue
that was already resolved of course it's
disappointing
that the senate didn't do their duty in
a manner that we felt was necessary
but i think the fact that they
themselves said
that we proved the charges mitch
mcconnell said
that the evidence we had made the case
should give the american people credence
and good comfort
to know that in fact it was true and
history has recorded this
we have seen what this president did we
saw over time what he did
to bring those individuals here to try
and overthrow the republic
to attempt to assassinate the vice
president of the united states
the speaker of the house in danger all
of the members not just
of the house and the senate but the
capitol police metropolitan police
officers
and the precious staff that we all have
here those that work in the house
for an insidious purpose for him to
maintain
power okay let's talk more about how
donald trump is reacting to the verdict
andy gallagher is in west palm beach in
florida
near trump's resort the one message from
that statement that was released within
minutes of him being acquitted is that
donald trump is going
nowhere he told his her supporters that
his
uh role to make america great again has
only just begun and there will be big
announcements
in the months to come so it's pretty
clear uh
at the moment this is in many ways
donald trump's republican party he
is a looming figure here but the wider
question is i think what does this do
to the republican party who are the
republican party
uh going forward are they people like
marjorie taylor greene who believes in
queueing on or are they people like liz
cheney
who voted against trump and is more of a
moderate republican
there's no question now that donald
trump has political plans going forward
the bigger question is what are those
plans
is he going to run in 2024 as many
people uh
believe or is he going to seek revenge
on those seven republicans
that voted uh him guilty in all of this
so we haven't heard or we haven't seen
uh from donald trump since this all
began this is the longest period i think
in the last few years that he stayed
this quiet for this long of course he's
not on twitter anymore one of his
favorite platforms
before he was banned from that and i'm
not imagining
seeing him on tv anytime soon because
it's the weekend here on monday it's
presents day which is a national holiday
and we all know that president
former president trump likes prime time
so
i i guess the country is waiting with
bated breath to see what he says next in
particular to see what he says about
mitch mcconnell after that scathing
speech
in which one of the most senior
republicans laid the blame squarely
at trump's feet i saw the 43 republican
senators who stood
behind trump house speaker democrat
nancy pelosi
hasn't been holding back but what we saw
in that senate today
was a cowardly group of republicans who
apparently have no options
because they were afraid to defend their
job
respect the institution in which they
served
alexander keyser is professor of history
and social policy at harvard kennedy
school
he says senate republicans who voted to
acquit will likely be seen
as cowards i think that the republicans
who have supported him
will likely be be viewed
as opportunists and to some extent
as weaklings as lacking courage i mean
the common view
and i you know i haven't done private
interviews with many of these
republicans or any of these republicans
but the common view is that if it had
been a secret ballot
um 90 senators would have voted to find
him guilty
they feared his reprisals
and they came up with a
technical pretext for
uh finding him not guilty i mean if you
listen to
uh to mitch mcconnell's speech his the
first 10 minutes of his speech is a
scathing indictment of everything trump
did and then he said
and of course he voted to acquit on a
technicality
i think that that will be seen as
cowardice and opportunism